PLENTY OF TIME.
THREE-POINTER.
THAT'S GOOD!
PAUL FROM DOWNTOWN.
NOBODY WAS NEAR HIM!
>> Mark: BAD DEFENSE.
I LIKE MONTY WILLIAMS GETTING
CHRIS PAUL BACK IN THIS BALL
GAME.
HE CAN REST TOMORROW.
LET'S FINISH THESE GUYS OFF.
>> Mike: GEORGE AGAINST BOOKER.
OFFENSIVE FOUL.
THAT ELBOW.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS PLAY A NUMBER
OF TIMES IN THIS CONFERENCE
FINALS.
A DEFENDER GETS UP INTO THE
OFFENSIVE PLAYER AND AS HE MAKES
HIS MOVE, THE ELBOW GIVES HIM A
SHOT TO THE FACE.
REMEMBER, BOOKER HAS A BROKEN
NOSE AND NOT WEARING A MASK
TONIGHT.
>> Mark: IS THIS A PLAY YOU TAKE
A LOOK AT?
>> Jeff: WELL, THEY ARE GOING
TO.
>> Mike: THAT HURTS EVEN WITHOUT
A BROKEN NOSE!
BOOKER IS SHAKEN UP.
HE HAD THAT EARLIER IN THE
SERIES IN THE SHOT FROM PATRICK
BEVERLEY.
NOW IT'S PAUL GEORGE.
THIS WAS GAME TWO.
YOU SEE THE HEAD BUTT.
INADVERTENT AND BEVERLEY IS
KNOCKING THE BALL AWAY.
HE HAD STITCHES AND THEY HAD TO
RESET THE NOSE.
>> Jeff: INTERESTINGLY.
CRIS PAUL IS SETTING OVER NEXT
TO THE CLIPPERS NEXT TO REGGIE
JACKSON.
>> Mike: I CAN'T IMAGINE HOW
MUCH THAT HURTS.
PAUL GETS OFF THE SIDEBOARDS AND
COMES BACK.
>> Mark: THE MORE WE COVER TEAMS
THE MORE YOU CAN FALL IN LOVE
WITH DIFFERENT TALENT THROUGHOUT
THIS LEAGUE.
DEVIN BOOKER IS ABSOLUTELY A
FRANCHISE HOME RUN TALENT AND
HAS AN EDGE AND IS CUT FROM THE
RIGHT CLOTH.
>> Referee: OFFENSIVE FOUL
AGAINST PAUL GEORGE.
IT IS CONFIRMED.
>> Mike: HE HAS THIS TOUGHNESS
ABOUT I AM HAD AND COMPETITIVE
STREAK THAT IS FUN TO WATCH AND
CLASSY TOO.
>> Mark: HE IS DETERMINED AND
XOTS AND RESPECTFUL.
HIS MENTALITY RIGHT NOW I CAN
TELL YOU I'M TOO CLOSE TO LET GO
OF THE ROPE AND I'M TRYING TO
FINISH THESE GUYS OFF, HURT OR
NOT HURT.
>> Mike: HE TALKS A LOT ABOUT
HIS DAD.
HIS DAD PLAYED BRIEFLY IN THE
NBA A